Japan's shrinking population is forcing
the country to look for new workers and
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a thinks he's
found the answer
women are beers outlined goals to create
a Japan in which women shine the name
given to it Womenomics but while
Womenomics has seen some success getting
more women into the workforce it still
faces serious cultural hurdles this is
your bloomberg quick take on the
challenge of breaking down gender bias
in japan by 2020 ARB wants 30 percent of
leadership positions to be filled by
women he's urged listed companies to
appoint women to executive our
managerial roles and he's working to fix
Japan's daycare shortage while
encouraging workplaces to be more
accommodating so that mothers will feel
more inclined to rejoin the labor force
and it is working sort of female labor
participation rate rose from 46 point
two percent in 2012 to 49 point eight
percent in 2017
but most of the women that have been
added to the workforce are working in
these relatively low paid part-time job
it's kind of a mismatch there with his
goal of getting more women into
management although while they
frequently tout the success of
Womenomics a closer look highlights a
work culture that systematically
excludes women
an expectation that women should stay at
home and be primary caregivers has
helped them back in workplaces all over
the world but in Japan that view is
particularly deep-rooted
a 2016 poll found that 45% of the men
surveyed agreed that women should stay
at home
Japan also has the third highest gender
pay gap in the more developed osed
countries although companies such as
Toyota are appointing female executives
change has been slow only 4% of the
managerial positions are held by women
in Japan compared with 9% in China and
17% in the US it's just very much the
working culture has built up around men
and around the long hours they work it
can be very bonding they got drinking
together in the evening and women simply
don't fit into that cosy little world in
a lot of cases on top of that just a
tenth of the members of Japan's lower
house are women ranking the nation among
the lowest and female political
representation in the world if you look
at promises cabinet in fact only has two
women at the moment out of twenty so
he's not really reaching his own target
of hovering 30 percent of management
taken up by women
some say quotas should ultimately be
legally binding for real change to come
about such measures could have great
economic benefit including one report
suggesting that gender parity could add
five hundred and fifty billion dollars
to Japan's GDP I don't think we're gonna
see a transformation overnight or or in
a couple of years these people are
obviously at the bottom of the ladder in
the corporate world so that they're not
going to be the ones deciding how the
corporate culture works for some time
you